hello I am Charlie Hunnam I'm Andrew
Golding I'm Michelle Dockery I am
Matthew McConaughey and we are here on
BuzzFeed playing whose ooh definitely
[Music]
Charlie's unless he's full of me where
she might be this way mom do not play
sweet in the movie he seems like he
loves his boss loyal is employer a
ballute lead works hard
absolutely you're basically dressed like
guy I'm just like you know you're just
like yeah yeah yeah and you're dressed I
get everyone just like that yeah yeah
that's great in a jumpsuit in those
heels don't walk in there 40 winks this
man - digs to take a nap on a film set
with ten minute break
takes a very simple heart there's meth
got a good she's even got a book where
he sees he's reading the pages under his
eyelids meditating mighty in the morning
cordyceps little jog at Russia lion's
mane no times from a - maybe no one
others nobody else's and besides is yeah
you doing everyone was I was the
[Music]
this guy from here this one's this one's
a little tasty on the map the roadmap
yeah you're a triple fine jujitsu name
in India yeah should she just shoot I'll
shoot yeah just got a little pistols
Karin in a little pistol six tiny
bullets no comment
[Laughter]
[Music]
and also Jeremy strong it'll actually be
guy guy you also not help that helps
things how is huge because you had the
most scenes with you I only hate acting
to me is hours of punishing boredom
punctuated by moments of total terror
yeah that says he has a way with words
you're one of the finest people I've
ever met he's the most miserable I sort
of described as like my granddad at
Christmas that always makes my rages
sort of comments you don't have to ask
him as many time you say hey don't you
just ask him if you seem an ally to ask
him the next day it's it goes from - oh
it seems you know potential morale
jeez would you like what happened 45
seconds since I saw you last time again
if you only knew
in real life guy yeah yeah just got a
napkin I mean over there guy he probably
changed outfits he probably had an
outfit plane ride home last night after
the event on the way to the airport I've
seen him change clothes in the middle of
the day I think I did yeah yeah not
because it got colder or warmer look you
get a biscuit
yes soggy biscuit I think I do we have
to give it six little baby bullets I
didn't I just couldn't give strength
babe I don't see I didn't ever see red
character maybe it's because you had
three page monologues every night yeah
but you were just hanging out that
morning yeah and you'd be like and then
you go walk off and study it yeah
come back at me just give me a minute
look in there at the ground going
and they need mainly we are the cost of
the gentleman check that in the t otros
us at the theater cinema sniffing you
British in this new decade yeah
this 2020 change your life another
classic January 8th iguana something to
look forward 24 have some fun
[Music]